get started for me are you are you
yeah
okay great so so let's get started um
welcome everybody and uh yeah welcome to
this um
um
uh
this edition of the of this simon
squadron colloquium so it's it's a real
pleasure to uh to have uh fermi ma um uh
speak today so fermi is a
is is a
uh is a simon's berkeley pro stock and
simon's quantum postdoc he he just
finished his phd
with mark zandry at princeton
and um on
on quantum security and fiat chamier in
cryptographic protocols he's been he's
been doing this beautiful work at the
intersection of quantum and and crypto
and uh
um really looking forward to to this
talk so
for me
all right thanks so much for the
really kind intro um
all right so uh i'll be talking about
post-quantum distinct arguments breaking
the quantum winding barrier um this is
the work i did uh princeton this is a
joint work with alessandra casa nick
spooner and mark sandry
so before i can do everyone can see the
slide okay this is
the right view
okay so i want to start off with a very
broad question um
why are quantum computers a threat to
cryptography
and i really want to explore this answer
um so to give a good answer to this
let's recall how cryptographers actually
prove security
i mean to say you've written down some
some cryptographic protocol or
construction and you want to show that
it satisfies some sort of security
definition
well the way you formally prove this is
your crypto security proof usually comes
with two components
the first part which is usually
necessary is this computational hardness
assumption and this is something like
hardness or inverting only function hard
as a factoring
and you couple this with a security
reduction
and the security reduction needs to say
that any efficient attack on your
protocol or in your construction
gives you directly a way to break the
underlying hardness assumption
so as long as you have confidence that
your hard problem is well hard then uh
you should be able to conclude that your
cryptographic protocol is actually
secure
okay so it's a really simple formula but
you know with this in mind why are
quantum computers a threat
and the simple answer to this that most
people are familiar with is well schwarz
algorithm is just going to break a lot
of the widely used hardness assumptions
all right so we're going to lose things
like factoring into street log which are
not hard against quantum computers
and unfortunately these are actually the
things that underlie a lot of the public
key crypto we use the internet today
so when it comes to building
cryptography secure against uh quantum
attacks aka post quantum photography
the minimum requirement is that your
underlying hard problem had better be
hard against quantum computers it's sort
of an obvious requirement
um the good news is that we have candid
hard problems so
for instance various problems on
lattices and misogynists
but a common misconception is that for
quantum attacks the only thing you need
to do is worry about the underlying
assumption that you can take sort of any
cryptographic protocol that you've
already proven secure and just swap out
a a quantumly broken assumption for a
quantumly hard assumption
and the reason this isn't the only thing
you need to do is that you're missing
the other half of the equation
and the key point i'm making here is
that the security reduction itself has
to be quantum compatible
so if you've already proven classical
security of your protocol then you
probably wrote down a classical
reduction
and formally what your classical
reduction shows is that any classical
attack on the protocol turns into attack
on the assumption
but what you want to do is couple your
reduction with your assumption right and
so if you want quantum security what
your reduction has to say is that any
quantum attack on the protocol leads to
a quantum attack on the assumption
right so um the question then is you
know what classical reductions are
actually going to be quantum compatible
well it turns out a good fraction of
classical reductions are sort of
trivially quantum compatible it's sort
of a matter of taking your security
proof and replacing uh probabilistic
polynomial time with quantum polynomial
time
but in other cases
this isn't the case in other cases the
the reduction may do things that makes
the reduction not quantum compatible
sort of the prime example of this is
rewinding the adversary
so for instance
um
you might have an interactive protocol
where it's proved secure by arguing that
midway through the interaction
the reduction can save the adversary's
state and then run it many times in
multiple challenges
so you might have something that looks
like this picture say a three message
protocol
where you prove security against a
malicious prover by having the approver
send a first message
and then querying it on some second
message and recording its response
so you write down this transcript and
then you reset it back to the adversary
state as it was after that first message
and then have a whole new interaction
from that point so you sample a new
challenge ask it a question get the
answer
record this and maybe your reduction is
going to use the the ability to record
these multiple transcripts to break some
hard problem
so this seems a little bit abstract
don't worry i'm going to make this more
concrete and give some
give an example that you can actually
feel later on
but this is basically the mechanic that
i'm talking about when i'm saying uh
that reduction may rewind the adversary
okay so the problem that we're
running into is that it's unclear how to
do this when the adversary is quantum
right so it's sort of
straightforward to say that if i have a
classical adversary i can just record
its state it's classical information
but if it's a quantum adversary then its
state is a well it's now a quantum state
and the problem is that um
you know when i when i run it the first
time i record this answer z
that might be a measurement of the
quantum state
and we might have an adversary that
detects this measurement and once it
realizes it's been measured it's going
to stop responding to you it's going to
stop giving you valid responses
and if your reduction is hinging on the
fact that you can get many valid
responses to break some hard problem
then it's not clear how you're going to
get any more after that first one
so this is really the core of the issue
so for this talk i'm going to phrase the
goal of rewinding is basically to solve
this problem that i have an adversary
that can answer me once and my goal is
to get my aunt my adversary to answer me
on multiple challenges and i want to
record its responses
so before i go on i want to have a sort
of brief disclaimer that this is you
know this is how winding is commonly
used to prove soundness but doesn't
fully capture applications such as zero
knowledge
where sometimes you might want to be
able to say simulate the adversary
states or maybe the explicit goal is not
to get multiple transcripts and record
them um but to get sort of one favorable
response from the adversary that your
simulator can deal with
um but if it's something you've ever
heard about before don't worry about it
it's not really what we're going to talk
about today
so
for today again the focus will be on
this problem of asking the adversary
many questions and and writing down its
responses
and in particular i'm going to make this
concrete and focus on one protocol so
it's a killian succinct argument
protocol
and there's a central result in
cryptography that really captures the
difficulty of this rewinding problem
so before i go on and uh explain what i
mean let me just recap what is asus
argument
so i'll be talking about distinct
arguments for np
um and basically in a nutshell the sync
argument lets you do is get it gives you
this extremely efficient way to verify
your mp statement
okay so we already think of np as these
uh statements that you can efficiently
verify but when we say efficient there
we mean polynomial in basically the size
of the witness
and succinct arguments basically let you
do much much better than this it reduces
the verifier efficiency all the way down
to being poly logarithmic in the size
the instance and the witness with the
original polynomial dependence on a
security parameter lambda
and the argument part of succinct
argument
is basically saying that you can only
you can only hope to get the
succinctness guarantee this uh this
massive savings by relaxing your
soundness so you no longer have uh
security against arbitrary uh cheating
strategies but only security against
efficient cheating strategies
so argument rather than proof
okay so a seminal result of killian from
1982 constructs a four message distinct
argument system so four uh four messages
back and forth from the verifier to the
preview verifier messages
uh it constructs this for all of np
assuming just collision resistant hash
functions or crhfs which is a pretty
mild cryptographic assumption
so let me sort of rephrase um this is a
really remarkable statement right it's
saying you know under a mild
computational assumption any np
statement can be verified in time that's
poly logarithmic inside the instance of
witness
so i think it's a truly remarkable
result
and of course there's been many many
applications of this in both theory and
in practice
um
but despite this like importance of
killian's protocol the post-quantum
soundness of killian's protocol has
remained open for sort of all this time
and the reason for this is uh in the
rewinding that's necessary to prove
soundness in particular the way that we
know how to prove the classical
soundness of killian's protocol
is to rewind the attacker many many
times essentially we need to get an
arbitrary polynomial number of accepting
transcripts from the adversary
and we do have some quantum rewinding
techniques but they're actually
fundamentally stuck at a far smaller
actually constant number of rewinds
so that's really the gap that we know
how to rewind an attacker a constant
number of times but the sound of sound
is that killian needs us to get all the
way up to an arbitrary polynomial
so in this work we resolve this problem
the
one-line contribution to this work is we
give a general rewinding technique to
rewind a quantum adversary as many times
as desired
and the
big consequence of this is that now we
know that killian's protocol is
post-quantum sound as long as the
collision resistant hash function is
quantum binding so this is a slight
strengthening of the classical notion of
collision resistance it's the it's it's
turned out to be that the standard
definition of binding against quantum
adversaries and this is the definition
of unruly and these exist under under
standard postponed assumptions such as
the quantum hardness of learning with
errors
another consequence of this is that many
other protocols so for instance
various things called sigma protocols so
examples are these three message
protocols by gmw and blum
these protocols have optimal
post-quantum soundness guarantees so
these protocols are previously proved to
be
post-quantum sound but with massive
losses and parameters and with this this
rewinding technique we can show that the
quantum security is essentially as good
as the classical security
okay so let me dive in and just uh
let's recall killian's protocol first
before we go into the rewinding details
so killian's protocol starts with a
problem checkable proof
and it turns us into a an interactive
argument system and using cryptography
okay so what do i mean um
a pcp is is basically a highly redundant
uh np witness and it's written in such a
way that i can have this pcp string down
as pcp string pi and a verifier can come
by and just query a few random positions
of this pcp particularly polylog number
of positions and be convinced with
overwhelming probability to accept or
reject
okay but this uh this pcp doesn't give
you a really efficient way just
for one party to convince another party
that an np statement is true because it
relies on this modeling assumption that
the string is written down first and
then the verifier comes by and randomly
looked at a few positions you can't
change the answers based on what the
verifier wants to look at
and so if you just sort of naively try
to turn it into an interactive
argument system interactive proof system
you're not going to get soundness it's
going to be possible to cheat by by
answering based on
what positions the verifier is looking
at
so killian's protocol uses cryptography
to solve this problem basically the idea
is to
have the approver commit first to the
pcp send a short commitment to this pcp
before you do the the pcp verification
so let me go into a little more detail
the first thing that prover's going to
do is take its empty witness and code it
as a pcp
it's going to get this collisionism hash
function h from the verifier
and the first thing it's going to do is
uh it's going to hash this pcp up in
this tree structure so it's called a
merkle tree
basically this hash function h has a
property that takes inputs of length 2n
and spits out outputs of length n so it
cuts the length in half
and so you apply this to blocks of size
2n of your pcp and this hashes it up and
now you have something that's half the
length
and then you just keep going you iterate
this process until you get a single crhf
output and that's going to be your your
root of your merkle tree and you send
that as the commitment
okay so this commitment has a property
that is short
so it's independent of the length of the
pcp
and the the the interesting property of
this of this commitment that we're going
to use is that it has this local opening
um
property so in particular when the
verifier wants to run a pcp verification
that samples pcp random coins are
and asks the prover to open this pcp at
positions corresponding to r so denoted
q sub r
this miracle tree allows the prover to
open this position and convince the
verifier that it's doing it honestly
without having to go through the naive
approach of revealing every single leaf
of the tree that's that's one way you
can open this commitment
but the merkle tree gives you a shortcut
it allows you to open a much smaller a
log number of positions
so in particular if the prover wants to
reveal the value of this black square
um then it can just look at the the path
from that leaf to the root
and include all the siblings along this
path so these blue squares
and
if the if the prover sends over these
black squares and the blue squares which
will constitute the the opening proof
then the verifier can just recompute its
way up the tree and verify that this
actually reconstructs the committed
value the prover sent earlier
so this will convince the verifier that
indeed the approver's answering honestly
and so in the end the verifier should
accept or reject
it should accept if and only if all the
openings are valid and the pcp verifier
accepts
okay so the intuition for stemness is
you want to show that the crhf's
collision resistant hash function
is forcing a a malicious prover to
respond consistently with some pcp
string pi
right and then uh and then you appeal to
the soundness of the pcp system that
says that if x is on the language then
there is no convincing pcp
so the way that you formalize this
though is well you can't just say that
there is some pcp and the approver you
know may be consistent or inconsistent
with it because you know where do you
get that pcp from
so the way you formalize this is you
rewind the last two messages many many
times you keep querying the approver and
random questions and get recording its
answers
and you basically piece together these
answers and you form a pcp yourself
and once you get enough of these answers
something interesting happens
so you record many of these accepting
transcripts these ri zi's
and these these answers are going to
overlap right the pcp is only so long
and you'll you'll query enough times
that you're going to have some overlaps
and either all these overlaps are going
to be consistent with each other
in which case all the answers ri zi you
get are going to piece together to give
some pcp
but what you can show that this is going
to be impossible because what's going to
happen is the pcp you construct is going
to have the same convincing probability
as your approver or close to it
and if your prover's success probability
is too high then such a pcp won't exist
so the only other option is that the
transcripts you're recording are not
consistent with each other that means
there's going to be some transcript like
some pair of transcripts that disagree
on some position
and the structure this merkle tree will
guarantee that any time that happens you
can find a collision in the hash
function
so this is really how the classical
reduction goes that um because the pcb
system is sound if you have approver
who's fooling your verifier eventually
you're bound to find a collision in the
hash function
okay so now i want to zoom in on where
all the action is happening which is in
these last two messages of the protocol
so we're basically playing a game where
i ask it a question i ask this prover r
i get an answer z and i record it and
based on some
public predicate v i either accept or
reject
okay so this is the game
i'm i'm going to remove the first two
messages of the protocol because i can
sort of
hard code them into this predicate and i
should note that this v is really
publicly checkable both the prover and
verifier can determine if r z will
convince the verifier
okay so this is the game we're looking
at and at this point the adversary has
some state s
and in the quantum setting this
adversary may have some quantum state at
this point and this is the state that
the prover has the adversarial approver
has accumulated by this point in the
protocol maybe he did some measurements
um
and did some arbitrary quantum
operations to send those first two
messages so now it has some quantum
state
and i want to talk about the success
probability of this quantum state s
in particular this is going to be the
probability that this prover with state
s convinces the verifier in this
interaction this probability in
particular is over the randomness of r
okay so let's be um this is going to be
the one thing to memorize that when i
say uh success probability of a state
what i mean is the probability of the
adversary with the state wins in the
game where i ask it a random question r
okay so here's our goal um
we're given some adversary state s the
success probability say one over poly
and we want to output many accepting
transcripts rizi i claim that uh what
we've seen so far shows that the
soundness of killian really reduces to
to this question can i do this
okay so for the rest of the talk i'm
just going to focus on on solving this
particular goal
alright so um just to
make sure everything's making sense
sandy check this uh you know when s is
classical this is a really easy thing to
do
right you can just run many trials
because after each trial you can reset
the prover state back to what it was
and so if you're winning on a one over
poly if you're winning with one over
poly probability in each trial then you
can get any number of transcripts you
want by running enough trials
okay but when s is quantum you can't
reset the state since a single trial
requires measuring this answer z and
that may disturb the state
and when we're concretely the reason why
we're concerned about about the state
disturbance is that the success
probability of the adversary may go down
so initially you have an adversary with
success probability p
and after querying it and disturbing the
state it's successful probability may
drop to something much smaller than p
okay so
uh what do we do in this work i'm just
going to give a
high level overview what we do and then
and then spend the rest of the talk
filling out this template
so what we do is we implement this
repair procedure
and the goal this repair procedure is to
reset the adversary's success
probability
so i'm going to take in this damaged
state this s prime and the result of my
repair procedure is a new adversary say
s1 whose success probability has somehow
been reset back to the original success
probability of p
and i want to emphasize that this
adversary is not necessarily the same as
the original one we had this s1 stage
could be different than my initial state
s
but that doesn't really matter the only
thing that matters is my ability to
record many transcripts so it's fine
that i have a different state now so
long as my new state still has that
success probability of p
and so now i can ask it a question again
get an answer i recorded something
transcript with good probability i've
damaged the state again and then i can
just re i can just keep repeating this
process
so every time i damage the state i have
to run this repair algorithm
and using this as long as my repair
algorithms repair success probability
enough i can rewind any number of times
i want to
so the focus of this talk is going to be
how do we construct a procedure repair
that sort of does this magic how do you
take a disturbed adversary state
um
and then restore this less probability
so before i get into the details of how
repair works i wanted to recall a
technique of unu that's going to make
our lives a little bit easier it's going
to sort of reduce the
the
magnitude of the problem we're dealing
with so what i mean is
using a technique of unruh you can
reduce the problem of measuring the
provers response to measuring the
verifier's decision
and intuitively this sort of this uh
this reduces the amount of disturbance
that you're causing to the to the prover
state
so let me explain
um
the way that you run this trial is you
ask a question r and then you record an
answer to z
and the naive way of doing this is well
the adversary in full generality is
repairing some superposition of answers
and if you want a classical answer well
you just measure the superposition right
away
so this is a
straightforward way to do it
but
there's also this lazy way of doing it
right
we use the fact that you only care about
recording z
when rz is actually going to convince
the verifier
so what you're going to do is take
advantage of that observation to limit
the disturbance and so
you'll leave z and super position
instead just compute first whether or
not the verifier will accept so compute
the decision of the verifier
and then only if the verifier accepts
are you going to go back and measure the
contents of the of the z register
okay so this is a
equivalent to the to the measurement on
the left except that it potentially
disturbs the adversary less
and the nice observation of unruh
is that there are certain protocols
where you can really take advantage of
this lazy measurement structure
in particular if your protocol has
unique responses meaning that for any
challenge r there's only a single string
z that would ever convince the verifier
then the step two measurement is
actually not going to disturb the
adversary state at all
right because
once you've measured that v of r z
equals one and you know r then z is
uniquely determined so the register
containing z can only contain a single
string and so measuring it is not going
to disturb anything
so this this lazy measurement really
reduces the amount of disturbance right
the
previously you were measuring a whole
string and now if you only disturb the
adversary's state in step one you're
only causing a one bit measurement of
disturbance to the adversary state just
the the output of the verifier's
decision
all right uh well killian's protocol
doesn't actually have this property it
doesn't have unique responses
however it turns out it has something
that's just good enough
it turns out that if the hash function h
has this quantum binding property i
mentioned it's also known as collapsing
then step two is computationally
undetectable to the adversary meaning
that
the adversary can't tell the difference
between two different worlds one world
in which i don't do the second
measurement and a world in which i do it
so therefore it suffices for the rest of
this talk
to only perform step one
we're just going to try to make the
verifier accept on many random
challenges
and the reason this is going to suffice
is that this will imply a full reduction
that performs both steps one and two
meaning that every time it queries that
actually records a transcript
and the reason this this suffices
because step two is computationally
undetectable so if your reduction is
going to work in the first setting it'll
it'll still work in the second setting
as long as your reduction is efficient
so the takeaway from all this the reason
why
we're calling uni's uh observation here
is that we've reduced this problem we've
uh we can just measure the verifier's
decision and so you only have to repair
the state after it's been disturbed by
this one bit measurement
okay so with this in mind uh let's turn
to the new stuff what do we do um how do
we implement this the state repair
okay so we have this new picture right
the difference in this picture is now
the
the output of the approver is only a
single bit this verifies decision
um
and the high level idea is uh
we're going to try to identify this good
subspace pi p
and by the way when i write pi p i i
mean really the i mean both a linear
subspace quantum states as well as the
projection operator the projection onto
the subspace
so i want to identify a good subspace pi
p
where
the original adversary state s is in pi
p
and moreover the crucial property
is that all states in pi p
have success probability at least p
this is the the defining characteristic
of this pi p subspace
okay i haven't said where this comes
from it should not be clear where it
comes from at the moment but let's say
magically that we have a subspace pip
that satisfies these properties
okay then the way that we're going to do
state repair is we're going to alternate
two projective measurements back and
forth
until the state is back in pi p and once
the state is in pi p then we know we
have a good state again because the
defining property of pi p's if you're in
the subspace you have success
probability p
okay so what are the two measurements we
alternate back and forth
the first is the binary measurement of
pi r
uh which corresponds to the measurement
that disturbed s
right so we initially had this state s i
said we did a binary measurement to
disturb it and produce this post
measurement state s prime
and pi r is going to be the measurement
that that we just applied so i'm
defining it so that
s prime is in pi r
um
but yeah so this is the measurement we
just applied and the measurement we
alternate this
with this is going to be um the
measurement onto pi p
okay so by the way when i write a binary
measurement i'm going to write it as a
tuple of uh
uh one projector and then the the
orthogonal projector
okay so um what we're going to do is
start from s prime this is start state
and we're going to first apply this
measurement onto pi p
and the goal is to is to try to get this
measurement to accept because if this
measurement accepts because it's a
projective measurement the post
measurement state is now going to be in
pipe and so our hope is we can apply
this and get it to accept
but if it rejects then what we're going
to keep doing is apply the other
measurement so we apply pi r
regardless of the outcome we have to
keep going apply pip
and this time say it accepts then we're
done
right now the the post measurement state
is in pi p
so there's only three measurements
because the slide is only so big but
this we could just run this for as long
as we need to until pi p accepts
so this is the the high level approach
that we're going to try to instantiate
okay so there's a huge missing chunks
here so first off how do you know this
process actually terminates like if i'm
going to keep alternating two
measurements back and forth until one of
the makes steps then i want some kind of
guarantee that this is not going to run
forever
and then the second
big missing chunk is where in the world
does this pi p measurement come from
right how do you measure that an
adversary has success probability at
least p
so it turns out that the first question
is a little easier to deal with so i'm
going to
resolve that detail first so how do we
know this process terminates
and the key is to use the fact that
these are our two binary outcome
projective measurements and imagine the
two-dimensional case where the picture
is really simple so if you're in two
dimensions and you have uh projection
as long as it's a non-trivial projection
and the
accepting subspace and the rejecting
subspace are just one dimensional spaces
and they form this right angle
and so if i have another projection pi r
then uh
this other right angle is going to form
a um
it's going to intersect with some
they're going to form a
an angle of theta with each other right
so pi r and pi p have an angle of theta
and my two states are going to be s
prime and s right so s is my original
state it's here in pi p and my disturbed
state is this s prime
and i want to label two more states so
uh s perp is a state perpendicular to s
and s prime perp is a state
perpendicular to s prime and in the
two-dimensional case these are really
the only four state that we're
interested in
because when you alternate the two
measurements back and forth
your state will always jump between
being in one of these four states
right so if i've applied the pi r
measurement and it rejects then i know
that i'm at the s prime perp state
right if i apply the pi p measurement
and it's accepted i'm at the s state
alternating the two measurements back
and forth i just keep jumping between
these states and the the behavior really
is determined by this angle theta
and what you can show uh based on sort
of elementary properties of these
productive measurements that if you
start at the state s in pi p
then you're going to return to pi p in
expected o of one steps for any theta
so it's a fun fact that this works that
this this returning to s is independent
of theta um
and you might think that maybe well that
seems sort of implausible right what if
pi r is really far away from from pi p
it seems like it might take a long time
to get back uh but the point is that if
if pi r takes like an almost 90 degree
angle with with pi p then you actually
had a really small probability of
landing there in the first place and so
that's accounted for in this expectation
okay so jordan's lemma extends it
extends this analysis to higher
dimensions basically this says that i
can consider for any two projectors i
can decompose a space into a whole bunch
of these two-dimensional slices and so
this this two-dimensional slice analysis
just readily extends as long as you have
the right sort of claim
and so the only property i'm using here
is the fact that these are two binary
outcome projective measurements not
using anything else about pi p and pi r
so that's the thing to keep in mind
and with that as long as we know these
measurements are projective then we know
that this process is going to terminate
okay so
uh maybe the more tricky problem um how
do we define this this pi p right i'm
claiming that we have some measurement
that measures whether or not an
adversary has success probability at
least p
and it turns out that as i've currently
specified it
such a measurement is unlikely to be
efficient something that exactly
achieves this guarantee
we won't be able to achieve
but with a
if we relax the guarantee a little bit
then we can use this beautiful technique
of mary and watrus to solve our problem
or to at least implement this this pipey
so let me recap what mary watchers do
they're they're concerned with this
problem of witness preserving qma
amplification in particular uh given a q
a witness state you want to compute a
really high precision the probability
the verifier will accept and using this
you can boost the um the complete
soundness gap of qma
but more generally what they show is
that given any binary output quantum
circuit c
so what i mean by that is a circuit that
writes its output onto a single register
that you can measure
and and along with the circuit you're
given an input state s
then there's a procedure to estimate the
probability that c outputs one and s to
arbitrary position
and so uh what i mean by estimate i'll
formalize on the next slide but
we're basically trying to compute this
probability
and the key is that you can do this with
only one copy of the state and so that's
why it's going to be useful for us where
we only have one copy of the adversary
state
okay so this can be done for any quantum
circuit uh and so i'm going to plug in
the quantum circuit that that makes this
procedure compute success probabilities
for us so remember success probabilities
are the probability you win this game
where there's a random r and i i measure
your response
so i'm just going to turn this into a
quantum circuit and the natural way to
do this is replace the classical
randomness with the superposition of all
challenges and the circuit runs the
adversary on this reposition of all
challenges and just measures the
verifier's decision
so if i run marriott watchers on this
particular circuit
then um
i'm going to get this estimator that
estimates my success probability now
because success probability is the
probability of circuit outputs one
okay so
for this talk i'm going to need two key
properties
um
about this narrative watchers estimator
so
the first key property
is that these estimates the the outputs
of this estimator is this p
they really have something to do with
the success probability p naught
so i have initial say s was
exceptionally p naught and my claim is
that the output of this estimator
uh the expected value of this output is
equal to my original success probability
right so it says your estimator
is is centered around the right um the
right mean
and the second key property we're going
to use
is this uh it'd be curious looking
property that says well if i run
mariette watchers once and i get the
state sp
then if i run it again
my next estimate is going to be fairly
close to my previous one
okay so uh i'm starting with n say s i
run merit watchers twice i get two
outcomes p and q
and the claim is that p and q are going
to be close with high probability
so formally this is some sort of epsilon
delta guarantee normally you can show
that the probability p and q are most um
are within epsilon of each other
is at least one minus delta
and to achieve these guarantees you need
to run your internal merit watches
estimator for some polynomial in one
over epsilon and log of one over delta
so in particular you can make epsilon
arbitrary inverse polynomial and you can
make delta some uh some exponentially
small value
okay so before i go on i want to um
kind of clarify that like while this
sounds like a really well-behaved
estimator um
its behavior kind of defies your
classical intuition really these these
uh these outputs p can be really really
uh like spread out
um the only thing we're saying is that
their expectation is p0
and moreover once you observe a
particular output then your future
estimate estimates are going to be
really close to what you just observed
if that sounds familiar that's actually
the sort of the defining feature of a
projective measurement right that the
measurement measurement outcomes could
be all over the place but once i do the
measurement once a projective
measurement has a property if i do it
again i'm always going to get the same
outcome
and so in that sense mariette watrus is
this almost projective measurement
the output is is like behaved in an
almost productive way
because i do objective measurement twice
i'll always get the same outcome here if
i do it twice i get two outcomes that
are really close
so i'm going to call this an epsilon
delta almost productive measurement
all right so now now i have this
estimator and my goal is going to be to
plug it into my state repair template
and see if i can use it to
to actually fix success probability
okay so recall where we were at we had
this high level approach in mind where
we were assuming this whole time that we
could measure this this uh projector pi
p this projection of the state the
success probability at least p
so in reality we don't have this but the
closest thing we have is
uh basically the analog of this
procedure using mario watrus
right so instead of exactly knowing
success probability what we're going to
do is run this measurement mwp
which i'm defining to mean the
measurement that runs marriott watcher's
estimation
and it accepts if the output is at least
p
and so this is sort of the closest thing
you can get
um
and we can easily swap out these pip
measurements for mwp this is a a binary
measurement right i'm only recording
whether or not the output is bigger than
p or not i'm sort of throwing away the
rest
so these are really binary outcome
measurements mwp
um
and so i'm going to swap out the pi ps
for mwp on my picture above
but i also need to update the invariant
that i'm maintaining and so previously i
was saying that the invariant we want to
maintain is that your initial stage
before repair
and your state after repair
are both in the subspace pi p and i was
using that as a proxy to say that the
state has good success probability
because being in pi p means your success
probability is p
but we don't have pi p in reality so i
want to phrase my invariant in terms of
a procedure i actually have
so fortunately there is a natural mario
watrus analog of being in pi p
so the way the way to think about this
is the the invariant i was maintaining
before is a property that if i were to
measure your state
with the pi p projective measurement it
would return one with certainty
the analog i have here because um the
outcomes of variant watchers i can't i
can't know a certainty
is that if i apply the marriott watchers
estimation procedure to your state
then it'll spin out an outcome that's at
least p with one minus delta probability
and turns out i can set this delta to be
the same delta and the epsilon delta
almost productiveness so this delta is
going to be
this alpha's going to be negligibly
small
okay
so what does this mean if i if i have
this guarantee that
the probability that mwp on s outputs
one with overwhelming probability
well in particular that allows me to
lower bound the expected output of
running a marriott watchers estimator on
your stage
right because i know that it's going to
if i run estimation on my state i get an
output that's at least p high
probability and so that means that my
expected output is at least p minus this
delta
and remember the defining or one of the
defining properties of this of this
estimator that we're using is that this
expectation is actually equal to the
success probability of s
so therefore this p minus delta lower
bound on the expected output of the
myriad watchers estimator also allows me
to say that my state s
has this monster test probability
okay great so now i'm gonna i'm gonna
swap out my old invariant for this new
one
um and i wanna note before i continue
that this guarantee necessarily degrades
the time so um
previously i was trying to restore this
invariant exactly but the actual
property that we we're going to write
down um is going to get worse
so the very first time that i i um
for my starting state s might satisfy
the guarantee that the estimator outputs
at least p with probability one minus
delta
but my my risk my repair state is only
going to have the property that we
estimate at least p minus epsilon with
probability one minus delta
and the reason for this is sort of just
zoom in on on the last thing that
happens which is that we measured the
marriott watrus
who measured mwp
and it accepted what does that mean
it means that i observed an outcome that
was at least p
and my epsilon delta almost productive
guarantee says that my next outcome with
at least one minus delta probability
will be no more than epsilon far away
but epsilon far away from p is p minus
epsilon so i can only guarantee that my
my new success probability or my new um
guarantee is a phrase in terms of t
minus epsilon so i have this loss here
but it's not going to be a big deal
i can set the epsilon to be as small as
i want so if i know how many times i
need to do repair
i can make sure this epsilon is small
enough that we don't have to deal with
it
but this is sort of the big qualitative
difference between what we can actually
instantiate and the ideal version of
what we want
okay
so this approach
seems quite promising
it's getting us pretty close but we do
have a serious problem
and the problem is that the proof that
we gave that this procedure would
eventually terminate
requires that these measurements are
actually projective
but this mwp measurement this binary
measurement i wrote down it's not
in particular there is always some
chance that if i run it twice you can
get two different outcomes
so this is sort of the the technical
crux of of what we need to resolve to
make this work it's that um we have a
really simple template that when you put
it all together it's going to do a
winding and the major component of this
template we already know how to do
but
actually piecing it together
they don't quite fit because what the
template needs from this piece is not
satisfied by by what this what the
destinator gives us
okay
so
maybe the most natural idea is well you
use the fact that any quantum
measurement in general can always be
made projective
as long as you you enlarge the space
that it's acting on
okay so this is a
simple quantum fact that i can define a
projector on a larger hilbert space now
so i'm going to start labeling my spaces
and originally my adversary state was on
this a register
and i could measure it with this mwp
and i'm defining this this projective
measurement pi p star
on a larger space so that applying pi p
star
to
s prime tensor 0 on the w register is
equivalent to applying the marriott
watchers
the mary watchers measurement on s prime
and so this uh this ability to take a
quantum measurement and make it
projective over a larger space
in particular the way you instantiate
this is by tensoring on some some
additional zero registers and then
applying a projective productive
measurement to this to this whole state
so from this point on a is going to
denote the the adversary register and w
is going to be this workspace and cell
register that you need to implement this
pip star
okay so
it seems simple but we have to be really
careful here
because the outcome of measuring pipey
star
only corresponds to this mario watchers
estimate
when the w register is zero
this is the i mean this is the the
definition of pipey star but in
particular we're not guaranteed anything
about the behavior of pi b star if i set
this w register to be something other
than zero
so for instance like regardless of the
quality of my adversary state maybe my
adversary is totally junk never accepts
or never convinces the approver the
verifier
um maybe i could have this useless
adversary state and tensor on like ones
in the w register and perhaps my my
projector always accepts when this is
the case
so i have to be really careful that i
only apply this pipey star in a way
that's meaningful because pipey star
only corresponds to marriott watrus when
the w register is zero
okay and
uh even if you start with the w register
initialize to zero before you alternate
your measurements back and forth
the problem is that you're you're
measuring this pipey star many times
potentially
and even the first time you measure it
it may ruin the w register and they make
it non-zero
right and once the w register is
non-zero
then just seeing this measurement
accepts does not necessarily tell you
that the adversary is doing anything
meaningful
so this is the
um
this is the problem with this uh
straightforward fix so just make it
projective and plug it in
okay so the key idea uh to resolving
this issue is you have to make use of
the other projector this pi r
uh which we sort of left alone this
whole time
and it turns out the right thing to do
and it's uh maybe not so obvious that
this is the right thing to do out priori
but you can prove it
the right thing to do is to extend this
pi r projector to also project the w
register onto zero
okay so intuitively the way to think of
this is that
you know pi r well pi r was the
disturbance of the adversary register
and it has this w register that kind of
is a it doesn't care about and i'm going
to redefine it to to force that w
register to be zero
and so this way
the the intuition is that when i
alternate pi r star and pi p star back
and forth the pi r star projection is
going to keep trying to reset your
ancillary registers to zero so that the
following measurement of pi p star is
going to be meaningful
okay so this is just intuition if not
formal and the problem is that this is
just a measurement right so it can't
actually force an outcome it can't force
the the w registers to actually be zero
because the measurement could reject and
the w register could be orthogonal to
zero so it doesn't quite capture the
intuition but that's that's sort of the
thing to keep in mind
um
and and with this this is essentially
the full repair procedure that all you
do is you start with your disturbed
state you tensor in a zero in the w
register
and then with these two measurements pi
p star and pi r star you alternate them
back and forth and eventually pi b star
will accept by the same argument we gave
earlier
then you get some adversary or then you
get some state psi that is uh defined in
these a and w registers
and what you're going to do is you'll
have to discard the w register because
that part doesn't correspond to the
adversary and then you get some state s1
and the hope is that s1
has some guarantee about its success
probability or in particular that it
the marriott watchers procedure is
likely to spit out at least t minus
epsilon
okay so uh what remains now that we've
stated the whole procedure is to show
that this actually works right that at
the end we actually have a state s1
satisfying this this invariant again
okay
so this part is uh
quite
quite delicate
and it's going to require a lot more
work so i'm just going to give a really
brief sketch of the the key ideas behind
it
and so
um
fundamentally the reason why this works
is
is a apparent when you look at the
two-dimensional case so let's let's
consider 2d so pi r star and pi p star
are now
right angles again in a 2d plane
and my my initial state is this red
vector this s prime the disturb state
tensored with zero on the w register
and remember that um
in the 2d case when i alternate pi r
star and pi b star back and forth i'm
just going to keep hopping around until
i'm at this particular green vector
which i'm labeling psi
and it turns out that the guarantee you
end up getting on the
the the resulting adversary state
which which is the the state you get
from taking a psi and tracing out the w
register
it turns out the guarantee you get in s1
at that state is going to depend on the
angle between this red vector and this
green vector
theta
and so
i'm saying gamma is equal to cosine
squared of theta in particular gamma is
equal to the probability that the pi p
star measurement accepts on s prime 0
which can be interpreted as the
probability that
mwp accepts on s prime
and so the conclusion you can get and
this is not um
this is not obvious from what's on the
slide but you can prove it
is that your eventual uh your eventual
state s1 will have the guarantee
that um the probability that the
marriott watchers procedure outputs at
least p minus epsilon on s1 is not quite
one minus delta but it's this degraded
guarantee of one minus delta over gamma
right where gamma is this cosine squared
of this theta angle
so um
what i'm saying here is that in the
two-dimensional picture the quality of
the guarantee depends on the overlap
between the red and green vectors
and in particular remember that i can
set delta to be really really small and
as long as i set delta to be
as long as this delta was exponentially
small i was saying earlier that then i
could conclude s1 has success
probability at least p minus epsilon
so here i have to worry about the
possibility that gamma is also really
small
right so for instance if gamma is just
delta then this guarantee is useless
right because then it's going to say
it's 1 minus 1.
so i need to make sure that the gamma is
not too small
and so that's the the tricky part about
doing the general case
is that to extend this two-dimensional
analysis to the more general case of
higher dimensions we're going to use
jordan's lumbar again and break down the
analysis into a whole bunch of these
two-dimensional slices
and we show that in the two-dimensional
slices where gamma is really really
small
your state cannot possibly have too much
weight there
and the intuition for this um i'm not
going to show it very formally but but
the intuition here
is like think about this quantity like
uh expectation of mwp on a particular
state
initially i had a state s
such that this expectation was large
like my initial state s had the
invariant right that
expectation of mwp and s was close to
one
and then i took my state s i disturbed
it by a binary outcome measurement
and the claim is that the resulting s
prime
uh
the expectation of this quantity on s
prime can't be that far away from one
minus delta like it can be small it can
be inverse polynomial um but that's only
going to happen with inverse polynomial
probability and it's not going to be
exponentially small except with
exponentially small probability
and so the key here really is that we
only disturbed s by a one bit
disturbance
and so properties that as satisfied are
not going to be you know that untrue for
s prime
and because of that this uh this angle
is not going to be that close to 90
degrees and that's going to enforce that
in all these two dimensional subspaces
my guarantee is 1 minus delta over gamma
where gamma is not that tiny
and so collecting this together you can
get some overall guarantee that allows
you to conclude that your state s1
has success probability fairly close to
p minus epsilon
okay so let me start piecing this
together
um before you do there's a question in
the in the chat that says um
um on fixing the w register why not just
uncompute it
why not just uncompute the w register
yeah
uh yeah so um
you can you can try to uh the problem is
that if you try to uncompute it um what
you'll what you'll see is that the
overall thing is not projective
um the the projective version of this
measurement we'll leave some garbage in
in the w register and
that you can't get rid of
um
there's another question in the chat
um yeah i can ask directly uh
so uh so for me is the procedure that
you use to estimate the probability p
uh in the in the approximate this
marriage rotors construction
is it related to quantum phase
estimation yes yes absolutely yes all
right okay thanks
um
so yeah maybe i'll just say a few words
about this
um
so i guess that there's a
yeah there's this algorithm that android
mentioned quantum phase estimation
and morally it's something very very
similar to marriott watrus
and the reason why they're sort of
thought of as two different things was
because
um at the time that mary watcher's paper
was written
the best guarantees and phase estimation
uh were not so good right it would it
would estimate your phase with some
failure probability
and what mary watchers showed is that
you can make this failure probability
like exponentially small
um
but since then like phase estimation
algorithms have actually improved and it
turns out by
um taking a whole bunch of like baby
phase estimation algorithms the same one
that you have in nielsen
and taking a median of all the phases
you can drastically improve the the
error
and um so using an improved phase
estimation algorithm you can actually
subsume the
uh the myriad watchers technique
um
i think that maybe the reason to use
mary watchers is that it's so much
simpler like you just alternate two
things back and forth you don't have to
do
like um
quantum fourier transforms and stuff
like that you don't have to think about
these median circuits um
and the the only price you pay for the
simplicity is that it's quadratically
slower and in this setting we don't
really care about a quadratic slowdown
and the reduction's running time
um so yeah i mean if the question is
about general connections to other
quantum algorithms right there's this
other algorithmic thing that i'm doing
here where i'm
also using alternating projectors to
amplify onto a state
and so what i'm doing here is actually
sort of a myriad waters version
of a general quantum procedure called
amplitude amplification
but the reason i'm using the the
marriott watchers version of it again is
because of these issues with success
probability right so the way that you
usually think about amplitude
amplification
is that uh you're trying to amplify into
a subspace with some constant
probability of failure
and if we did that here like we would be
um
it wouldn't work right because you can't
incur a constant failure probability of
your repair step every time
and so you know marriott watrus is this
way to ensure that if i'm in a subspace
a and i want to go to a subspace b
then i can just keep alternating these
two projectors on the a and b back and
forth until b accepts
and i know that you know as long as the
success my state is exactly where i want
it to be
um and and this only fails with this
like
exponentially small probability
so um there's really like yeah there's
there's basically two core sub-routines
here uh a phase estimation to learn
success probability
and an amplitude amplification to
amplify back onto states with good
success probability
but the key is that i don't want to
incur any
any like noticeable failure probability
in either the subroutine because i'm
going to keep running them polynomially
many times and so that's why it's it's
hard to plug in like
how these algorithms are written in the
literature directly into our setting
and so that's why we sort of do these
like in-house solutions using mario
watchers and the the nice
the nice uh
property of various watchers is your
algorithms are really simple
um
are there any other questions
um think it's good
okay
um
great so let me just uh
bring this home um
okay so to recap the full rewinding
procedure um how do i start with an
initial adversary and get a bunch of
transcripts
um
so it's basically what i've been saying
there was one detail i was missing out
or i wasn't mentioning
which was uh how do you get the
invariant to be satisfied in the first
place
because so far we know how to say if i
have the invariant being satisfied that
marriott watrus will likely output a
high estimate then i can satisfy it
again
but uh it's not the case that the
initial adversary satisfies this
invariant
so the way that you satisfy it is fairly
straightforward you just run the mario
watchers estimator
okay so you get some estimate p if p is
too small you you abort the whole thing
it's not worth it but if p is large then
the invariant is satisfied in particular
it's satisfied for for p minus epsilon
this epsilon degradation is inherent
um so after this initial merit watch
estimation from this point on you you've
kick-started this procedure you've
satisfied the engineering for the first
time and now you can rely on this repair
procedure to allow you to run it run a
trial um and then repair
um
but before i go on i just want to
recap here when i'm running a trial and
asking the question r and getting an
answer z remember i'm doing it in this
sort of careful like lazy way where i'm
not actually measuring z but i'm
actually first measuring if z is
accepting and then only measuring z if
it is
so that's what this uh z denotes
so anyways i disturb my state then i run
this repair step
and all this repair step does is takes
my
disturbed state s1 prime
introduces this w register of zeros
and then alternates my two measurements
back and forth
until finally the the pi p epsilon i p
minus epsilon star measurement accepts
discard my w register and that is my
repaired state
now i satisfy another invariant it's
epsilon worse and then i keep going
and that's it that is the the whole uh
quantum rewinding picture uh for
killian's protocol
and so for killian right you just
instantiate this game to be the game at
the end of killian's protocol and
eventually you're going to collect
enough accepting transcripts that will
either give you a pcp or a hash function
collision
okay so just one quick concluding slide
um i mean the the focus of this
talkboard broadly right was these
problems that arise when you look at
interactive protocols which are sort of
like the the most interesting results in
crypto come up when you allow parties to
talk back and forth
and in the quantum setting you know
security is really fragile because your
quantum adversaries don't play by your
your classical intuition particular the
the key technique we use in thinking
about interactive protocols improving
their soundness is this ability to say
well if you could do something once you
can do it again
and this sort of allows us to really
understand what interactive algorithms
can do in the classical setting
um but these these techniques that we've
relied on for so long just don't really
apply to quantum attackers
and so today we focus on one key
application of rewinding which is to
write down a lot of adversary responses
and the way we address this was by
solving this abstract problem which says
that if a stateful quantum adversary is
winning this challenge response game a
single time
then given just one copy of its date i
can make this adversary win the game
many many times
so javi's next steps are you know what
are the other use cases for a winding
right this is a as i said this is not
the only kind of way we use rewinding in
crypto there's other things you want to
do besides just record a lot of
responses so for instance and
in applications such as zero knowledge
the goal may be to simulate the
attacker's state
eventually after recording a lot of
responses
and so we give some answers uh to this
in upcoming work with uh alex lombardi
and nick spooner and this should be out
in hopefully a few weeks
right so uh thanks everyone for coming
with your attention this has been a lot
of fun
thank
you fantastic
um so let's see are there any more
questions
hey fermi um
thanks for the awesome talk
so a quick question about the
uh you said that um because you're not
dealing with exact projectors
um you have these approximate projectors
so when you when you do the alternating
things a bunch of times there's some
degradation
um
is this like a a real problem or like
does it actually
result in some loss in security as
compared to like what killian achieves
or
is this just totally like um you know
you
um like it's not a real problem i don't
know if that question makes sense yeah
yeah i know good so i mean one thing it
does mean is that uh you know because
uh the success probability is going down
then you have to run for a little bit
longer right so your reduction takes
more time um right to get the same
number of transcripts that you do in the
classical setting
um
so it does mean you your reductions take
longer and so you get like
less efficient adversaries that break
your underlying heart problem but the
key thing is that you can tune the
epsilon to be as small as you want it to
be any inverse polynomial
um so in terms of like
concretely does it do worse and like i
think the usual metrics no
um but like conceptually yes the
reduction is running for potentially a
little bit longer
got it
thanks
sorry just clarification
and the more and the smaller you make
your epsilon longer your
uh your procedure has to be right
yeah yeah so i have been kind of vague
about what i mean by this epsilon but
basically if you have some success
probability p
then it's almost always the case that it
would be fine if it were p over 2.
so you just set your epsilons so that
you would never drop below p over 2.
right so
you can do this if you know how many
times you need the adversary to answer
correctly
makes sense
um
if i may ask uh about this um so about
this reconstruction procedure um can you
maybe go to the previous slide that just
have
um
so right so just oh yeah this one yeah
um so this this marriage watchers thing
it's like sort of
i'm not sure i understand the invariant
here because you you only you get the
success probability and expectation so
can there be like some noticeable
probability where you just fail and it
throws you into a state where you cannot
from which you cannot recover or
something like this um so it throws you
into like a probability zero
um
[Music]
yeah um yeah so what is the what is the
invariant here and how does it sort of
make sure that you can you can
with with um overwhelming probability
just keep going you don't sort of fail
in the middle yeah no no so um
uh okay maybe i lied when i said this is
the full full procedure there we do
these little checks here and there to um
to sort of reset the error uh back down
to this delta
so
and we do incur some failure probability
so for instance once you have your
repaired state
what you can do is just run a fresh
merit watchers estimator on this
repaired state
and now this has sort of reset your your
failure probability back to delta
and
you can uh
um and then you can say well if this
estimator gives you a really low
estimate then just abort the whole
procedure
um
so yeah in our inner full thing there
there are these small like negligible
chances you incur that you you fail and
and the whole thing's over
um i mean in the indeed in the initial
estimator if you fail then you fail
right then you cannot proceed right i
mean the uh on the initial adversary
when i run yeah if mw estimator outputs
something that's like negligibly small
for p then it's done
but so why can't this so how come this
cannot happen in your like sort of
in the following uh
mw estimator executions
yeah good
um
so what we're basically maintaining is
that uh
um
right so as i mentioned earlier this
this mario watchers estimator has a lot
of variants in its outcomes
right the outcomes can i mean think of
them as their outcomes between zero and
one and in that very first mary watches
estimation the only thing i know about
this distribution of outcomes is that it
can be arbitrarily well spread through
zero and one uh just that they're
centered at p
right um
it turns out that the thing that we're
insuring when we restore um the state
is that
the
the outcome distribution of this merit
watchers estimator is really
concentrated
like really really concentrated around
where you where it should be
like that's that's the key thing that
makes this work
um because if it weren't concentrated
then exactly what you're saying could
happen that uh you know if it's well
spread then i can measure it get a
really bad estimate and it's over but i
have to make sure that every time i do
the estimate there's only a tiny like
negligible chance that it's far from
where i want it to be
and so
um
the key thing is that
like the property of being in this pi p
star
subspace
as long as i alternate with the right
projector
is that once i get back to it
the thing we're proving is that the
state we've gotten back to has a really
concentrated
like distribution of merit water's
estimates
uh am i could i like am i supposed to
understand why this is the case or it's
like a technical
or it's a technical reason
um
yeah so
if you stare for a really long time
you'll you'll see that the the
concentration you want is implied by
this expectation i wrote down uh but i
don't think it's like
super obvious
thanks
okay good job
so
um no more questions and let's move on
to the panel so actually can i uh yeah
sorry one more thing to answer
um
so it just occurred to me to say this
that um
maybe think about like what this
projector pi b star means
right like
what it's saying is that uh
i like being in a projector like if i
have a projector in general and i have a
state in that projector what it means is
that if i'm to measure that state with
this projective measurement then i'm
certain about the outcome
right
here my projector corresponds to running
the marriott watchers procedure and
getting an outcome that is at least p
right and what i'm restoring is i'm
basically restoring the property of
being in this this image
and so when you translate that into what
it's saying about marriott watrus it's
saying that i have a state such that if
i ran marriott watchers on it
the estimated spits out is at least p
with overwhelming probability
why is it overwhelming probability
because
because you landed in the because you
started from the subspace
um yeah so i guess
so i i guess i know what i'm saying is
kind of approximate like it's not this
is not true for all states and it in
particular we only prove it for like the
certain states we repair back to but i'm
saying intuitively like think of being
in a subspace as as saying well my state
has a property that if i did this
measurement i have certainty about its
outcome and i'm saying in this case the
measurement is
i applied married watchers and the
output was at least p
and if i'm certain that this outcome
will accept or that the measurement will
accept
that means that my state has a property
that
if i applied marriott watchers to it the
like the sort of distribution is really
supported on like p and greater
and so if that weren't the case i
wouldn't actually be in this in the
image of this projector
okay yeah that
gives an idea at least thanks
okay great um okay so
thanks uh thanks for me so let's let's
move on to the panel so tell me if you
could stop sharing and
then
i think we have the